so what do we have right here well this
is just a this is just a water molecule
and this right over here let's see we
have one two three carbons in our
backbone so this would be math earth
propane
we all have single bonds right here so
this is propane we write that out this
is give myself some space propane and
then on the number two carbon I have
both a methyl group and a bromo group
and ro bromo comes before methyl in
alphabetical order so I could write this
as two bromo to bromo two methyl to two
methyl methyl propane so that's this
molecule that we have right over here
now what we're going to imagine it's
sitting in some water and I have one
water molecule drawn right over here
let's imagine that we have look we have
this bromine right over here it's pretty
neutral and it's neutral because it has
or it is neutral because it has seven
valence electrons one two or you could
say that or it has a charge equivalent
it has one two three four five six and
then it has half of this bond that's
composed of two electrons so that's
what's keeping this neutral right over
here but we do know that bromine well
you know it's it's it's not completely
unstable if it were to take an electron
because that would get it to eight
valence electrons we know that it's more
electronegative than carbon which means
that if it's sharing a bond it's more
likely to take the entire bond then
carbon is so let's imagine a scenario
let's imagine a scenario where bromine
takes these two carbons in this bond
right over here and this is going to be
a super fast thing that happens because
this molecule right over here the to
bromo to methyl propane is actually
reasonably stable so I'm not saying this
is going to just happen automatically
it's going to happen super fast but it
could happen and so to show that this
isn't going to be a you know only a
one-way reaction I'll show that it's in
equilibrium so the equilibrium I'll draw
two arrows like that and so once this
happens the bromine would turn into a
bromide anion so let me draw it right
over here
so the bromide anion so it's going to
have one two three four five six and
then both electrons from that shared
bond both electrons from that shared
bond it now has a it now has a negative
one charge now if that happened what
would happen to this left over - I guess
what's now going to be with this this
the the the the thing that the bromine
was connected to I guess you could say
well let's draw that so we have this
carbon our number two carbon we have ch3
right over there let me go back to a ch3
and then I had this blue methyl group so
I had this blue methyl group right here
and the way I'm drawing it it kind of
pops out of the page my best attempt to
draw it popping out of the page so this
is it popping out of the page and now
what's its charge going to be well it
just gave up half of this bond the
equivalent of an electrons charge so it
just gave up you can kind of think of it
as giving up an electron so this is
going to have a positive charge this is
going to have a positive charge and a
positive charged carbon like this we
would call this a carbo cation so this
right over here is a carbo carbo cation
positive charge and the reason why this
is not a crazy thing to happen is that
this is a tertiary carbon which means it
is connected to three other carbons one
two three a tertiary carbon one way to
think about it is that this this this
this positive charge can kind of be
shared with its brothers a little bit
more so tertiary tertiary carbo cation
is more stable than a secondary
indefinitely more stable than a primary
secondary would be if it was only
connected to two carbons but this is
tertiary so let me write this down this
is a tertiary carbo cation it's because
this this carbon is connected to three
other carbons that's where the tertiary
comes from so once again it can happen
I'm not saying that this reaction is
just going to go super fast in that
direction that's why we did these
equilibriums this is these equilibrium
arrows now let's bring this oxygen into
play
so let's bring
now let's bring this it's not sorry not
the oxygen let's bring this water into
play so this water as you can imagine
the water is neutral it might seem it
seems pretty reasonable in the state but
it does have a pox egde intend of the
water does have a partial negative
charge we've seen in the past we've
we've seen in the past that because
oxygen is a lot more electronegative
than the hydrogen's that you have a
partial negative side on the side of the
oxygens and you have a partial positive
charge on the side of the hydrogen's on
the side of the hydrogen's and so you
have this positive carbo cation this has
a partially negative charge so you could
imagine that this this molecule might be
attracted to this nucleus now it's not
going to be super attracted the way that
a hydroxide anion would a hydroxide ion
has a full negative charge this only
sets a little partial negative charge
but it could still be attracted to
something very positive like this so
this situation the water molecule is a
weak nucleophile so this is a weak a
weak nucleophile no not as strong as a
hydroxide anion that has a full negative
charge but if it's easy something
positive like this and it bumps in the
right way you can imagine that one of
these pairs of this oxygen would then go
one of these pairs on this oxygen would
then go and essentially form a bond with
this carbon making this carbon making
this carbon right over here neutral so
what is that going to look like and this
might happen a little this would happen
faster so I'm not going to do this as an
equilibrium this could happen like this
and let me let me just copy and paste
the bromine so I don't have to redraw
the whole thing so let me copy and let
me paste it so that's our bromine right
over there right there actually let me
erase that little this little smudge and
make sure it still has a negative charge
so negative charge it's a bromide anion
now and now let me draw the everything
else so I have this carbon
this carbon let me scroll down a little
bit to have some space carbon out the
carbon in the back
ch3 I have the carbon on top ch3 I have
the carbon in front I have the carbon in
front like that ch3 and now my oxygen or
that I should say this molecule right
over here the water molecule has
attached to the carbon so these two
electrons you could say they've attacked
the carbon they now form a bond with the
carbon they form that so those these are
those two electrons in this covalent
bond and now let's draw the rest of this
so you have oxygen you have these two
electrons right over here these two
valence electrons and then you have one
hydrogen and then another hydrogen now
what is going to be the charge what is
going to be the charge right over here
on the oxygen well it was at a partial
negative charge just because it's more
electronegative but it just gave it just
gave the essentially half of a bond half
of a pair it's now sharing or it's now
sharing a pair with this carbon so it's
equivalent of giving up one electrons
equivalent of charge so you would now
say that this thing right now has a
positive a positive charge so you could
imagine you could imagine maybe another
water molecule comes along maybe another
water molecule comes along and draw
another water molecule right over here
we're sitting in water so there's plenty
of water molecules so another water
molecule might come along and say okay
well you know this is this this thing
right over here is positive but this the
oxygen is hogging is is hogging these
bonds a little bit more than the
hydrogen's especially now that it's
become positive and so this might give
its pair to a hydrogen proton and then
this hydrogen and then this bond with
the hydrogen will go entirely entirely
to entirely to the oxygen let me draw
that in a different color so this bond
this bond right over here goes entirely
goes entirely to the oxygen
electronegativity means if there's this
is more electronegative than that that
if a bond breaks at that pair is more
likely to go to the more electro
negative the more electronegative
molecule or I should say the more
electronegative atom so what will this
look like when all is said and done so
let's draw an arrow like this so let me
draw my mean my main molecule so I have
the carbon it has bonded to another
carbon right up there it's bonded to
another carbon right over there we have
our carbon in front we have our carbon
in front just like that we have the bond
with our oxygen so we have our bond with
our oxygen right over there
so that's our oxygen and we have this
bond with a hydrogen this bond with a
hydrogen we have this pair and now it
has gained this pair it is gained this
pair that was with that hydrogen so just
like this this is now neutral I went
from being positive it over here it only
had half of this bond so it's kind of
the equivalent of one electron charge
now it has the whole bond so now has
equivalent it has literally has both
electrons so now this thing is neutral
and now this molecule right over here
becomes a hydronium cation let me draw
that so this water so let me see so
that's the two hydrogen's right over
there this is that pair that is on top
and now and now it has sharing it is
sharing this pay this this pair with a
hydrogen essentially with a proton so
with the hydrogen with this hydrogen
right over here with this hydrogen right
over here and now this will have a
positive charge this is a hydronium this
is a hydronium cation and maybe this
bumps into another water molecule and
does the same thing with it and it just
keeps going on and on and on and of
course we can't we can't forget we can't
forget our bromide anion friend so
there's our bromide anion friend got a
negative charge right over there and so
what are we left with well we are left
with well there's a little bit of
there's there's a there's this hydronium
cation as a positive charge you have
this bromide anion
and now what is this molecule now called
well we'll go into more detail in the
future but when you have a hydroxyl
group attached to the carbon backbone it
is an alcohol and so our main backbone
once again has one two three carbons so
that tells it's probe but instead of
just saying propane its propanol so
let's write that down
this is probe probe probe on and some
people say just propanol generally but
if we want to be a little bit particular
this is the the hydroxyl group is
attached to the number two carbon so we
would say probe on to probe on to all
and of course we still have this blue
methyl group so we could say 2 methyl -
2 methyl will make this 2 methyl propyl
2 all is what we are left with now let's
think about what we could name what we
can name this reaction we just saw well
we've just substituted a bromo group
with a hydroxyl group so I think it's
reasonable to say that this is going to
be a substitution reaction substitution
and we substituted with a it was a weak
nucleophile but it was a nucleophile
nonetheless so it involved a nucleophile
nucleo file but this one unlike the sn2
reaction in the rate determining step
and this is the rate determining step
this is the slowest step of the process
everything else will just kind of kind
of start happening once this thing
happens this thing kind of is in
equilibrium this is the rate determining
step only one reactant is involved in
the rate determining step one reactant
in rate determining step rate
determining step and this in this case
it was the bromo group so you might
guess what we're going to call it its
substitution involving a nucleophile so
nucleophilic substitution you can
imagine stands for a nucleophilic and
only one reactant is fall is involved in
the rate determining step
so this right over here this whole
reaction that we've now drawn is an sn1
reaction